Missouri Republican governor Eric
Greitens once considered a rising star
in the GOP has just resigned this
afternoon amid an impeachment efforts
marked by a pair of scandals we've been
covering here on special report for
weeks first to our mid-war at west
newsroom and courts on that finn with
the breaking story I'm governor bright
good evening Matt Breck good evening
governor Grimes was mired in mounting
legal trouble and scandal and it was
clearly taking a toll on his ability to
lead until he resigned a short while ago
there was an act of special session in
the Missouri House to consider whether
Greitens was going to be the first
governor in Missouri's history to face
impeachment proceedings and Greitens was
also facing a second felony trial
related to misusing a donor list now a
short while ago the governor formally
announced his resignation however even
on his way out the Republican governor
insisted he is innocent and chose
careful words to strike back at those he
believes wanted to take him down this
ordeal has been designed to cause an
incredible amount of strain on my family
millions of dollars of mounting legal
bills endless personal attacks designed
to cause maximum damage to family and
friends and it's clear that for the
forces that oppose us there is no end in
sight I cannot allow those forces to
continue to cause pain and difficulty to
the people that I love today's
announcement comes exactly two weeks
after governor Grimes was found not
guilty on his first felony charge
related to a picture he allegedly took
and transmitted of his mistress that
photo never materialized in the state
dropped the case against the governor
but Grimes was also charged with felony
tampering of a computer related to
misusing a donor list for political
purposes today a judge ruled his team
would have to turn over paperwork
related to that second charge this very
long saga of scandals involving the
governor who was just inaugurated last
year finally comes to a close this
evening right
Matt Phair live in Chicago Matt thank
you very much